tomorrow marks the first day of fall I I
know it's crazy we're getting ready for
the season at Gilcrease Orchard and
Jillian takes us inside to see how there
are they're prepping for pumpkin picking
check it out
well we are officially getting ready for
fall here in Las Vegas and we are at one
of my favorite spots I think it's kind
of a Hidden Gem it's Gilcrease Orchard
it's been around for a while I'm here
with Mark thank you so much for having
us out here you're welcome the most
perfect day to be out it is and
hopefully this weekend will be too yeah
so you guys have your official grand
opening happening on Saturday so when
people come through what do you have out
here what can people will find so we'll
have apple picking we'll have pumpkin
picking we'll have apple cider donuts
and cider cucumbers and two sunflowers
and other things you had me at apple
cider donuts are always
I think it's so cool out here especially
in Las Vegas we don't see this a lot
everything is fresh you guys throw it
out here we're looking at pumpkins over
here which obviously is exciting for the
fall so tell us a little bit about the
history of the Orchard and you know why
you guys are such a staple here in Las
Vegas well Ted and Bill Gilcrease came
down with their families about 100 years
ago and they had a bunch of property and
this is where they made an orchard back
in the 70s 1970s and so we've just been
trying to make it as good as we can if
it's still going strong and I grew up
here in Las Vegas so I remember coming
here on field trips with my class and
that's something you guys still do as
well right yes we do a lot of field
trips so the kids can come out and they
can pick their pumpkins and what makes
the perfect pumpkin I remember always
looking like I don't know where to start
and there's different ones that you can
find out here right so we have all kinds
of colors and shapes and sizes so just
pick one that is not soft so fill around
for it to be soft if it's really dark
green it's not not quite ready and if
it's super small
a light green it's not ready either but
there's plenty that are and so just
bring some shears fill around if there's
any soft spots that room won't be any
good and when you come out to the
orchard you show up here and you can
actually grab a wagon right if you want
to collect things how does it work is it
kind of a free-for-all you can grab what
you want so we encourage you to bring
your own wagon okay but if you can come
out and you can pick and it's by the
pound so 75 cents a pound for pumpkins
the fruit is two dollars a pound and
everything else is out of price all
right well you can't beat it it's so
much fun and after we leave the pumpkins
here I gotta find one for myself for
Halloween um we're gonna go check out
sunflowers you have a corn maze a lot
more to talk about right right all right
Mark well thanks for having us out here
you guys I'll check back in with you and